Well,
hello, how are you? Sal and Jaramillo greet you
with the brief information for today, Tuesday
, March 16. More than a million doses of
the vaccine against the virus were placed
in the arms of Nevadans. The
vaccine is now available for people
over 55  with
pre-existing medical conditions some of these
conditions include obesity
cancer dawn syndrome and diabetes
for a complete list of eligibility
visit our page at disney.com
diagonal in spanish
the mexican consulate is offering
another round of vaccination on  Today
this will be to give the first dose and the
service will be given only for
those with a scheduled appointment. They will have
Spanish-speaking workers to
help with the process. For more
information, visit Disney.com
Diagonal in Spanish
and if you are driving near Rainbow  and
then you will notice something different in the
pedestrian crossing metro officials together
with the school agents in haiti and the
authorities  It is new beams they will be
enforcing safety in the
streets with a goblin those
drivers who do not respect the goblin or
a pedestrian using the
assigned pedestrian crossing will receive a fine
and now we turn to the weather forecast
the sun will rise today the maximum
will be in  62 degrees and minimum in the
40s and get ready because it is approaching
temperatures above normal to
end the week have a nice
day I am salt and haram and today this was your
brief informative of Vince Neil in
Spanish